this show is about you and you are just
inspiring okay because you hear all the
stories of these little snowflakes who
can't get a job right
can't find something in my area of study
and so I live in my mother's basement
till I'm 38 you hear all that crap right
I hear these people
I got participation trophies lining the
wall right you hear these people and
then you talk to that last guy his wife
is disabled with a neurological disorder
to the point she can't get her own kids
ready for school her parents have to
help her he loses his job in Mississippi
and what does this man this manly man do
he commutes to Baton Rouge how does he
do this as only you could do in
Mississippi he traits the case of beer
and a lawnmower for a van always my soul
touchdown if you could trade this
negotiation went down a lot more I don't
know about a lot more I'll throw in a
case of beer done what kind of beer this
was that's what I want to know you know
he's not even 30 years old and he
doubled his income making $100,000 a
year working as an electrician on the
railroad
away from his family in order to take
care of his family you didn't hear him
whining at all he's living in the van
during the week while he's in Baton
Rouge and he goes home to see his wife
and kids on the weekends he's sleeping
on the floor of the van and just
cheerful not whining
not entitled not mad at Obama or Trump
not trying to figure out how some
socialist is gonna fix his life he dove
in the back of the van and took care of
his family that's freaking inspiring
it's inspiring what a guy I mean you
should be lucky enough that your
daughter would marry a man that would do
something like that to take care of his
family
that's who you ought to interview for us
to find a guy with a backbone like that
I mean this guy's doing it and not only
that he's willing to do it for two more
years
so that his house is paid for so that
when he goes back home and takes his pay
cut in half everything will still be
okay with his family because he's
experienced being jobless and doesn't
want to feel that feeling again now we
were cutting up with him and you know I
couldn't resist he's living in a van
down by the river I mean still starting
that live skate with Chris Farley right
you'll end up in a van down by the river
you know I mean remember they're scared
right but all that aside just listen the
one thing I was doing and who does that
real people every day and that's why
some of us have no tolerance for you if
you're one of those whiners there's no
jobs out there in the Trump Obama
economy
you just can't we must resist you little
whiner well I got dove in the back of a
van that he traded for a case of beer
and a lawn mower translation this ain't
much of a van boys and girls and he's
sleeping in it you listen I don't hear
your whining on my tolerance for whining
for the next hour and a half is zero
I've just used it up on him because he
didn't whine
Wow Wow you know what this means you
know if you listen to that I would you
do that I'm not doing that I mean I I
probably would have when I was 28 I
probably did stuff like that when I was
27 you do whatever it takes your hustle
grind feed your kids done some pretty
wild stuff I've worked a lot of hours of
my life I've done some pretty nasty butt
jobs that nobody else would do just to
make a little money to keep the lights
on I've done all that I've opened the
front door when the wolf was standing
there I know who he is
the wolf at the door but you know what I
I got I got an answer truthfully the guy
I don't know if I've never been away
from my family for three years and some
of you that serve in the military are
gone like that all the time thank you
for your service
I can't emotionally relate to it I so
honor you I so appreciate you if you're
willing to do things like that for the
good of your family the good of your
country that's called serving that's
called sacrificing for others and that's
what the guy was doing now maybe you're
not willing to do that but maybe you're
sitting there with a $60,000 debt on
your freaking Tahoe and you're whining
about having to get rid of that to get
your life cleaned up and this guy just
made you look like a fool he made you
look like a complete wuss you're sitting
they were dead up around your eyeballs
all your little lifestyle and your pride
and you're unwilling to break that and
this got dove in the back of a case of
beer van and took care of his family
Wow we salute you sir
appreciate the humor appreciate the good
humor in your voice and in your
character and it's a great story because
there's a little humor in there with all
the pain but wow wow
so would I for another two years do that
if I were him I doubt it I think I would
find another way to pay off my house I
think I would go back home be with my
wife and kids take a pay cut and but
let's not assume that it's all the way
down to fifty thousand let's try to find
something in the 75 to 100 range maybe
you start your own electricians outfit
because you obviously have a lot of
initiative and maybe it's time to start
your own business and maybe it's time to
do some other stuff but what I know is I
don't think it's just do I do fifty or
at home and a hundred there no I think
we do more than 50 and we go home and
that's what I would do I appreciate your
willingness to do what you've done
it was very manly of you to take care of
your family very manly of you but I'd
probably go home and find a way to make
a little more money than I used to make
and be there with the wife and kids it's
just too hard to be gone that much
thanks for the call